all the friends how much we love Nina do
you like the museum here Evan oh yes
every it was small every room was
different like the Louvre we were
running through the whole thing and
didn't get to everything so here you get
to see everything yeah nice and strong
[Music]
the whole town is
the stairs
up the top of the tower and then touch
the lucky hour lucky owls at the end
[Music]
good morning day something in Paris
we're going to breakfast and then we're
gonna go to the Dijon I slept well Nina
did not sleep as well but you still got
a good sleep score no it was interrupt
okay tell your story no it's not good
it's interruptive it got too hot last
night I think it too I mean I've been
hot every night I don't know how you
were you had like an extra blanket on no
it was really hot I was sleeping outside
of the blanket but I did not it was
still very hot anyways
okay I was sleeping now I slept you
don't want to talk to the camera perfect
okay we just hear them a beautiful voice
like the angels from above
okay here we go
okay so we finished a breakfast and I
went back to the hotel to hotel room to
have a shower and then now we're heading
you notice my hair no you know now we're
holding now we're heading to I don't
know where we're going we're going to
the train station we're gonna go to
Dijon home of Dijon mustard and other
amazing things so it's windy and we're
heading off to the subway to then head
to the train and hopefully I don't mess
up like I did yesterday on directions
and we get there on time let's go
[Music]
all right we have arrived in Dijon the
train was very fast at one point they
almost went at 300 kilometers an hour
yeah that was very fast got a little
nauseous I had to look straight ahead my
ears pop up a few times no quite a few
times for the last for the first half an
hour it was not very comfortable but
anyhow we arrived we're gonna meet
um
member Alberto yeah and we're gonna tour
duck City exciting
okay
we found him
[Music]
foreign
Palace
[Music]
[Music]
do you like the museum here Evan yes it
was small every room was different yeah
has its own art nice to yeah like the
Louvre we were
running through the whole thing and
didn't get to everything so here you get
to see everything yeah
I don't know where are we actually next
Alberto's our guide yeah where are we
out to Alberta
in Tower we're gonna find some stairs
foreign
so we got the ticket we went to the the
tour information center got the tickets
to the tower but next step we're gonna
go to uh grab some coffee chill a little
bit and eat our delicious um Donuts from
Alberto and now we're gonna continue our
day after that and then the lucky hour
oh and then the lucky hour Evan said we
have to touch the lucky hour
you want you to give you a lot of luck
so
thank you
yes
but the bottom was because it goes it
Curves in it's like a it's not flat see
it's like oh yeah I see you yeah dig in
all right this is almond
and sugar it looks like it'd be
raspberry or something oh good
the outsides
harder than I thought it would be like
very thick crust
how's the break Evan good yeah we had
some good snacks we had a good coffee we
had a good conversation yeah but now
we're gonna say something yeah we're
gonna go climb 300 stairs up the top of
the tower and then touch the lucky owl
it's kind of a lucky owls at the end and
then we're gonna go home
let's go I liked it yeah yeah good view
you did a pretty good job of explaining
translating yeah she was talking in
French and I I was translating to Nina I
got I got enough checks yeah but it's
good we got it
now we're heading to see the lucky hour
we have to touch it with our left hand
let me make the wish any other anything
else we have to know that's it touch it
with your left hand
and make a wish let's go
where's the owl oh you can barely see it
this is the good luck owl you have to
touch it with your left hand and make a
wish and then it's for sure gonna come
true why you can't even see that it's an
owl anymore it's all been rubbed off
gotta make a wish
[Music]
thank you
I'm gonna go over the clutch to here
next to here that's the belly I can
reach
so did you feel that your wish will come
true yeah
now we're gonna head to the church I
think we're gonna be a little quieter
because it is a church pay some respect
the church is little different I haven't
small but different as its own yeah yeah
it has its own characters this is a
market it's closed
we're planning to get some Dijon mustard
but we can't take it home maybe get a
small one really small one yeah that fit
into the pouch and then go souvenir size
yeah
will we will we even open it or yeah
yeah no we'll see okay let's go see it
we got some local Dijon mustard when
you're in Dijon you have to get
something local
look at those nails too guys
we're off to
stop at a church along the way we'll see
we'll see what Adventures find us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay we're heading back to the train
station
we are done it was a good trip that was
a good trip a day trip that was a great
day trip yeah it's a great day trip
yeah glad we thought of it well I guess
I thought of it yeah you thought of it I
didn't plan this I'm glad I thought of
it great idea Evan
okay let's go to the train station
what's the Highlight the highlights
no you said the Hutt is The Owl and the
view and the view view is great yeah
meeting Alberto yeah and uh and the
Dijon mustard that we're yet to try yeah
but I'm excited for
foreign
thank you so much for meeting us
later to a guy yeah
so it was interesting it was great
thank you so much have a safe trip back
bye
oh [ __ ] day Evan thought it was a good
day yeah good day still still more days
and we love Nina so
we're at the train station we're here
like what time is it we're here about 40
minutes early
and uh just waiting for our train to
come in and then it's a quick train was
going at 300 kilometers an hour it's
fast so quick train ride back to Paris
and then hop the subway and back home
and then we'll see how our energy levels
are doing
we'll be back just around dinner time so
we'll see where we want to eat and
finish off today
[Music]
so we came back later than expected yeah
we should have just stayed for the
restaurant
find the Metro
uh where are we to go and then we're
gonna go back to the hotel then find
something to eat can we pick up the food
and then um everyone was on my phone the
whole time because I I didn't film The
any other stuff I we pick up Thai food
we're gonna eat something it's already
10 o'clock yeah
because hello
because I want to film you
delay for two hours ten o'clock
some dinner
so I got pineapple fried rice look at
that it's actually in the pineapple and
I got a tom yum soup for myself I love
soup and a pad thai
it's the wife look at how special she is
we are done for the day and if you want
to see we have a good day oh yes
wow
let me explain what happened after okay
let me explain okay okay I had a huge
headache
yeah I I I kept forgetting I'm I'm
actually allergic to MSG she said she
was craving noodles but I want to eat
something French yeah because we're
friends right so then we ordered Thai
yeah that's perfect yes
we have a very exciting day planned
tomorrow and we want to see we're gonna
see well it's amazing
everybody gets amazing tomorrow you want
to see go watch your video here we'll
see you there believe